the Prolog collection was designed for
scanty scanty produces a furniture using
solid teak wood we designed this
collection with the Japanese market in
mind this was the crucial part of the
process where we made a decision to do
the research and to let the compositions
and stories with the Japanese customer
inform the design when we did the
researcher in Japan
certain insights we got such as when the
customer see more of the floor or more
of the walls true the furniture they
feel that the the space in their small
homes feel more roomy and most patients
for example the swivel bench in the
collection which a lot of times in a
small home setting a piece of furniture
is utilized for different purposes and
functions so that was what inspired us
to design a bench of the backrest that
enables you to swivel and face both
directions this kind of insights that we
get from the customers through the
research trip that we made was very
valuable in helping us shape the
eventual design the reason why I think
the collection is successful is probably
because people can relate to some of the
design decisions that we made such as
making the bookshelves
shallow instead of D making the dining
table not as deep as the usual dining
table so that you feel more spacious we
don't have a set design style or fixed
design philosophy in our studio but I
think what we tell the world is that we
don't apply any fixed formulas to our
projects which means we approach each
project on a fresh page we feel very
honored of course to win the president's
design award we would like to thank
everybody who has contributed to the
project well I think that having
accolade
such as the president's design work
definitely push people to innovate and
to have bigger goals for their designs
my advice to emerging designers is
design is not just about getting to the
end product but also the process a good
process and that will get you to the
good end result